now this might get awkward for  anti-socialist christian conservatives  but the new testament is also chock full  of socialist themes jesus advocated that  all people including governments should  provide for the poor and distribute  resources according to people's needs  some quotes from the new testament all  who believed were together and had all  things in common and they sold their  possessions and goods and divided them  among all men as every man had need  and the multitude of them that believed  were of one heart and of one soul  neither said any of them that ought of  the things which he possessed was his  own  but they had all things in common if you  would be perfect go sell what you  possess and give to the poor when you  give a feast invite the poor the maimed  the lame the blind and you will be  blessed because they cannot repay you  distribution was made unto every man  according as he had need to take another